I know mine really now what would you do
Pride and Prejudice yeah I've read it
and I've watched it many times it
surprised me every day thanks God is
that hand flinched it's that hand Flinch
he does this little hand thing oh yeah
that was not written and it was
improvised but oh it's just I would do
either The Princess Bride or The Devil
Wears Prada I'm doing Devil Wears proud
that's old school man yeah that's like
old school dividend I would say I've got
to see The Hunger Games
because it's the only one where I've
read and watched it I think it did a
good job at accurately bringing the
words to the screen you know
okay sorry